يا وحشن انتفض من كابوس مزعج او قيلوله
طويله امتدت ل 50 عاما انتفض بركان
كوبريبيه خا ليدخل سكان جزيره لابالما
الاسبانيه في كابوس كبير انتهى بنجاه
ارواحهم لكنه شردهم ودمر مصادر ارزاقهم
فماذا حدث
منذ اخر ثوران للبركان عام
1971 اختار بركان وكوبريبيه التاسعه عشر
من سبتمبر للعام 2021 لينفو ثانيرانه في
جنوب جزيره لا بال اسبانيا فعند الساعه
الثالثه عصرا بالتوقيت المحلي وبعد ان
سجلت الجزيره اكثر من 22.000 زلزال خلال
اسبوع في المنطقه المحيطه بالبركان بدات
الحمم البركانيه تتدحرج من شقوق الجبال
باتجاه القرى ما اربك حركه السكان بدات
الحمم المنبعثه من البركان تتجمع على شكل
سيل البركاني اتجه نحو عدد من القرى
المجاوره فقامت السلطات باخلاء قرى الباسو
ولسيانوس دي اريدان القريبه من البركان
بعد ان كانت قد بدات باخلاء العجزتي وبعض
حيوانات المزارع من القرى المجاوره وتم
انشاء ملاجئ للمتضررين حيث تم اجله اكثر
من سته الاف شخص من منازلهم بينهم 400
سائح كانوا بالفنادق
التقطت الاقمار الصناعيه صورا جويه تظهر
الحمم البركانيه والصخور المنصهره وهي
تحيط بالعديد من القرى حيث تحولت الوان
المنازل من الاحمر الى الاسود نتيجه اكسده
المواد المنصهره كما تركت كميات كبيره من
الرماد على مدارج مطار لا بالدولي فالغت
شركه الطيران رحلاتها واغلقته السلطات
لمده اربع 24 ساعه
وفرض حظر على المنطقه المحيطه بالساحل
ومنعت القوارب من الاقتراب
تسابق المزارعون مع الوقت لجنى اكبر قدر
ممكن من محاصيل الموز والافوكادو والعنب
خشيه وصول الحمم البركانيه الى مزارعهم
وحرق المحاصيل لكن الحمم التى تزايدت
سرعتها تقدمت الى قلب الجزيره وبلغت
الساحل لتلحق اضرار للمزروعات والبنا
التحتيه للجزيره حيث تدمر نحو 14 كيلو
مترا من الطرق بسبب الحمم البركاني
شهود عيان وصفوا الحدث بيتسونامي من الحمم
البركانيه بعد 10 ايام من بدء الثوران وصل
التدفق الى المحيط الاطلسي وهبط جزء كبير
منه في المياه ما ادى الى اطلاق غازات
الكلور وحمض الهيدروكلوريك في الهواء وهو
ما يضاف الانبعاث كميات كبيره من ثاني
اكسيد الكبريت الناتج عن الاحتراق وهي
الغازات التي تمثل تهديدا لسكان الجزيره
على الرغم من عدم وقوع اصابات حتى الان
الا ان الخسائر الماديه الناتجه عن
البركان كبيره فالتدفقات البركانيه دمرت
اكثر من 2100 مبنى معظمها منازل وتسببت في
تشريد نحو سبعه الاف وخمس مئه شخص من
الجزيره التي يقطنها نحو ثمانيه وخمسين
الفا كما دمرت اكثر من 900 هكتار من
الاراضي الزراعيه بشكل رئيسي
وبحاسب تقديرات تورس فان قيمه هذه الخسائر
تتجاوز 400 مليون يورو في الثالثه عشر من
ديسمبر اعلنت السلطات انتهاء ثوران
البركان الذي عاد ليكمل سباتا لا يعرف احد
متى سيصحو منه مره اخرى
[موسيقى]